Elsa gum resumes here on the put-upon
channel we only play the most hardcore
badass and MLG games as possible so
today we're gonna play Bill Cosby fun
gamers yep this is three free games with
parents I like the idea behind it and
it's to make better videos for your
breath so I'm not trying to copy anyone
is this we play on hard because I'm not
a [ __ ] alright so in this game you are
Bill Cosby as you can see and you have a
camera and you have pudding and you need
to use these two to get cash would you
like some pudding say we got three cash
there but we lost some hiding [ __ ] got
two puting from us Getti Merry Christmas
indeed alright here's another one
play it cool hey you want some padding
touch me at six pudding nice son of a
[ __ ] get it you greedy [ __ ] you had
six putting's already how about you we
want to cut it five cash oh my god Merry
Christmas
bye you you what you went some padding
no it's a padding touch me again and
you'll die next year you're dead
get it all right you want some padding
you want some padding
I lost how's it possible how does that
get in a Cell no money by of seven cash
Wow what's over here I can buy a shovel
and put in who are you you have great
taste in Swedish vodka alright nice
boobs by the way must be all the pudding
get in it well you know what at least
better gameplay than Minecraft what the
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to sell Steve Oracle
now no one is bidding come on Steve
Urkel Jewish thank you
finally so in price I love it neighbors
are complaining buy a shoal to dig a
deeper hole
alright so no cutting for the boob man
yes you get padding come here oh my god
it's amazing I'm so rich look at his
[ __ ] face so content
who can say knit know from from free
pudding from this face who could ever
say deny a pet in you made a big mistake
[ __ ] get it hey guy you want some pot
in oh no get in hey guys you want some
pudding
oh no get it hey guy you want some
padding
oh no good I got you may have boobs but
you're not a girl you're not fooling
anyone
okay you want somebody oh no god dammit
I can't bribe them now
why did they arrest me I don't
understand most unrealistic game ever
[Music]
great story at least this game is a
great story I'm gonna complete this
[ __ ] [ __ ] with last thing you'll ever
do Oh goddammit neighbors are
complaining buy a shovel to dig a deeper
hole goddamn it I'm gonna have to sell
my most prized possession
Steve Urkel nobody's bidding what how
does it make any sense come on Steve our
fabric on shoes thank you
stupid Steve Urkel cost me a shovel okay
so I need hundred of them to make the
cash call got it
I don't know why I enjoy this game so
much did I tell you to take my potty
Merry Christmas piece of me let's give
it hardball all right it's free to
attempt to his suicide you know I wasn't
gonna do whatever it cost me like five
bucks that doesn't seem like a good deal
to me don't you [ __ ] he had nine
puddings who walks around with nine
pudding anyone would breasts bigger than
my face that's a yes what are you what
we did impress oh my god
fresh ending of all the time what does
it mean
[Music]
this song always had forever
so let's all hold Bill Cosby we'll all
do that that was that was worth it
that was totally worth the effort I
think there's anything I learned from
that is to not take pudding from
strangers
all right next game has been rated the
next big thing in tween gains must play
from IGN it was like being on stage
Justin Bieber Oh Ted why haven't I not
played this sooner is the real King
question well for a Justin Bieber game
this sure takes a lot of time any day
now I can't wait anymore
oh my god it's starting what is this
what is happening how much I'm not gonna
be Biebs go okay sing so well Bieber
loved it really hitting those high notes
aren't we
that moment when your mouth goes through
your eyelids that moment define your
eyelids are like bigger than Jesus
alright so next up we have the horror
game that should be great shouldn't it
all right
this one has a tendency to break the
fourth wall make sure that the area
behind you is free of fragile all right
I'm fine a game by submaster cr7 for
like I really got the best name ever
quick huh it's all of us to be played at
night well what are you gonna do [ __ ]
and play this is the tiniest resolution
I have ever played a game on but we're
in lavender chime it's lavender lavender
I don't care hi I have terminal Oh
flower sorry about that
where say that the ladies hello but
where are all the pokemons
I thought I was playing a Pokemon game
maybe I'm the only one but I love the
lavender town because you could always
catch the coolest pokemons they're like
galleon game nore and all that [ __ ] this
town has been getting more and more
adult I'm thinking about moving out soon
alright well you're not really the
cheapest boxing
shut up all right sometimes you hear
voices at night oh thanks for telling me
sometimes the area voice is at night do
you really think I believe those things
all right [ __ ] you better stop trippin
cuz I will be flipping you off there
aren't any good person in this world
some will do anything for money okay
just because I did that one Harlem shake
video doesn't mean I'm of you [ __ ]
alright god damn it I'm going god dammit
I can't go anyway
alright he looks like he knows what's up
team plasma is that what the kids call
it these days
Team Rocket for life yo don't say you're
ever again
team driving has been bombing Lakes team
I find mag my resurrected to Pokemon
that hated each other but we Team Rocket
have it oh there we go kill an entire
family of Pokemon and let the sole
survivor where'd his [ __ ] Oh
mothers skull and he will roam around
the grave for eternity
it's it talking about cubone inside his
name I don't remember my Pokemon died
last year I come to the tower every day
to pray for him well that's a sad that's
a sad sorry anything happening in this
game sorry the game is not finished you
can't quit with while a [ __ ] what am I
supposed to deal with that it doesn't
even say you can't quit with watch where
the white son of AB I'm the link between
this world and the other well that's
good for you
what no no no no no no no no
I'm sorry I wasn't looking that poor
okay I'll do it
all right okay then you killed my
pokemons I get it I don't know why you
would do that we got you you son of a
[ __ ]
you have mentioned terrible I guess how
do I get out of here make it stop
Megan Fox hello
oh god this is so trippy Oh what all the
people go Jesus I can't do anything oh
god what was that
dad was not a polka man I know
specifically because I've seen a couple
of pokemons in my days hello oh god
they're all dad
what did you do to them finally I'm here
yet the game is not meant for everyone
well [ __ ] you to tell me that now it was
all right hand
[Music]
what the [ __ ] did you know after
negative run now you work I don't want a
good job you have been through this
experience and stayed alive thanks for
enjoy this relaxing music - coming down
thank you okay then
alright that was three free games and
thirds hope you bros enjoyed go ahead
and leave like if you did I'd really
appreciate it and he support means a lot
to me but thank you for doing that and
the brofist to you Brophy